obviously you've had a ton of experience
both before facebook and at facebook
with payments uh you recently wrote a
piece that identified a lot of the
problems with the legacy payment rails
and maybe you can kind of just walk us
through what some of those problems that
you've identified are and kind of why
they're problematic both in the united
states and outside the u.s
well i mean the main reason they're
problematic is because they leave so
many people and businesses behind
and we kind of think about financial
inclusion as a problem that is not an
american problem and that's absolutely
untrue
uh there are over 62 million adults in
the u.s who are currently unbanked
and left behind by the current system
about 70 a little shy of 70 of the
payment volume in the us still goes over
ach which was built in the 70s and takes
three days to clear
um so you know we think that that's not
okay and then when you look at it from
the global lens then you have 1.7
billion people who are left behind by
the current financial system and about a
billion that's underserved because they
just were born in the wrong place or
live in the wrong place and i feel that
the way that the system is set
is actually done in such a way that uh
the least you can afford it the more
penalized you are by fees and all kinds
of different access problems and we feel
it's just time for a change
as a matter of fact it's actually
overdue
when you think about uh internationally
i think a lot of folks would say okay i
expect there to be high percentage of
people who are unbanked um maybe i can't
determine exactly which country i can't
determine exact numbers but that makes
sense to somebody that grew up in north
america but to hear that 60 plus million
americans are unbanked or under banked
uh i think it's shocking why do you
think that number is so high is that
something that is
kind of systematic is it an education
thing is it a technology barrier what's
driving that
so there are lots of different reasons
and and when we started on this journey
we wanted to make sure we talked to
many people who were actually in in that
in that
place where they didn't have access to
the current financial system or decided
proactively to not be part of it
and what we found is actually that a lot
of people can have access
to having a bank account or opening a
wallet for payments uh but they decide
not to because they've been burned in
the past by unpredictable fees that are
actually you know just withdrawn from
their balance at the time they can
afford it the least and so they actually
prefer to pay
10 percent
uh for
a
check cashing operation uh at one of
these places that are payday lenders
rather than have a bank account just
because of the predictability of that 10
percent um and so you know that that
says a lot about how the current system
is is designed now and you know people
who are more fortunate like you or i um
we have all of these fees waived so we
don't have atm fees we don't have um you
know overdraft fees we don't have
um all kinds of other things applied to
our account and in in the us right now
if your balance falls
uh under a thousand or fifteen hundred
dollars um at any given point in time
some banks actually charge you a fee
uh for having a bank account and so just
people can't afford it
yeah it's absolutely crazy when you
start to break it down i remember
somebody one time told me that the top
four banks made like eight billion
dollars in overdraft fees and the way
they pitched it to me was uh they
basically were taking money from folks
who didn't have money right and so it
definitely is a scary situation um you
came from paypal before you went to
facebook and i always tell folks the
story of uh i don't remember if it was
you uh stan or other folks on the
messenger team when i was at facebook
but that was the first time i'd ever
heard about bitcoin specifically uh and
like a fool i brushed it off and in fact
they didn't do too much research uh wish
i had listened a little bit look at what
happened since
i i atoned for my sins but uh but
definitely made it made a mistake there
um walk me through kind of your journey
with bitcoin and and kind of
cryptocurrencies in general how did you
come across this and and was it
something that you were excited about
right away did it take some time to
learn about it just walk me through kind
of the beginning
so yeah i think the first time i came
across bitcoin was probably in 2009
late 2009 or early 2010 so really really
super early in the process
um and
i started looking into it and then i'm
like okay this is like way too geeky
and i don't right now have the time to
actually you know really understand it
fully
um and i kind of brushed it aside and
then it came uh back
in to my life uh in 2011
um
when a number uh of friends uh and
people here in silicon valley started to
be
excited about it and then i actually
gave it a really legitimate shot at
trying to understand
uh and as you know because you've been
talking about this way more than i have
over the years now um even though it
happened later
maybe
it just takes a ton of time to really
really truly understand
uh what is behind bitcoin how it was
created how it's able to sustain all
kinds of different attacks over the
years and all kinds of unforeseen events
um and so that's when when i really
focused on it is you know late 2011 and
then it uh carried me through uh through
to uh 2012
um and uh and i've been a fan since then
i think uh i think it's just an amazing
creation and um and you know that i
don't think can be replicated or will be
replicated ever so it's got this
uniqueness to it that i find uh really
appealing um in this current economic
climate
bitcoin's always one of those assets
that uh i describe to people
folks will be able to understand how it
works if you tell them but they'll say
yeah but that's not possible right like
theoretically that would make sense but
you can't actually have a decentralized
currency etc and as you kind of disprove
their skepticism they slowly become more
and more convinced uh which i think
everyone kind of has to take that that
timeline if you will what's up guys bang
bang thanks so much for watching the
best business show today if we're going
to be the best business show we
obviously need the best partner that's
why the exclusive sponsor the best
business show is sofi they're an
all-in-one platform that allows you to
invest in all kinds of different assets
including stocks etfs crypto ipos and
they even have an automated investing
function if that's your thing so before
we start getting after it again make
sure that you go download sofi you get
an invest account and when you make your
first crypto trade regardless of what
you buy they'll give you 10 in bitcoin
for free it's that simple head on over
to sofi.com to get started today thanks
so much for watching and i hope you come
back and watch more of the best business
show tomorrow
[Music]